we faced a challenge like this the last
time sixty to seventy years ago at the
end of the Second World War when the
European international system that had
been dominant that time had been
devastated at the end of the at the end
of the war and we had visionary leaders
like Roosevelt like Truman like Dean
Atkinson in the United States Winston
Churchill in in England cotton Konrad
Adenauer
in Germany John mone in France and
understood that they needed to create a
set of institutions that would be
conducive toward stability and
prosperity so we got the United Nations
we've got the World Bank the
International Monetary Fund the European
Union to be at least the beginnings of
that and NATO a set of institutions that
actually led to a long period of peace
and prosperity and justice at least in
that part of the world not dominated by
communist systems and beyond that a
system that was resilient enough to
stand up to the challenges posed by a
hostile Soviet force the question now is
whether you will have the type of
visionary leadership to take advantage
of the opportunity now to build that
type of World Order now we're doing it
now when the challenges are evident but
at a time when we haven't gone through
30 years of war and economic collapse
the way those visionary leaders did 60
to 70 years ago and the question is can
we draw the lessons of the changes in a
sense preemptively or do we have to
awake for the for the real challenges
the real disasters to happen before we
see the wisdom of operating in a
different way well there have been some
efforts to what to deal with the changes
we've seen a debate on how the UN
Security Council is structured we've
seen some changes in the way the World
Bank and the IMF allocate voting rights
within their system but all of this has
really been too little to deal with the
dimensions of the challenges we're
facing so the real question for the next
decade is whether those new leaders will
emerge whether the new ideas will emerge
that will help put us on a path towards
greater peace greater prosperity greater
justice or who we failed to come up with
those ideas fail to come up with that
leadership and find that the crisis that
we're facing now only deepens